en fait ce que contient un attentat on
est censé laisser un traitement qui est
sur l'émotion et qui nous emmène vers
des discours qui peuvent être des
discours qui vire à l'identitaire à la
xénophobie ou est ce que nous y mauriste
on a pour but de mettre des uppercuts la
définition de l'humour selon françois
cavanna de charlie hebdo c'est que
l'humour c'est des grands coups de poing
dans la gueule moi j'ai envie de mettre
des grands coups de poing dans la gueule
à l'heure qu'il est j'ai des mecs qui me
propose de mettre des grands coups de
poing dans la gueule en pensant que
c'est de l'humour il ya une grosse
grosse nuance en vrai si geof ans des
gens avec mes blagues les gens sont pas
obligés de regarder mes blagues à la à
l'heure qu'il est longue on est en train
de me proposer des menaces de mort des
appels au suicide de menaces et ma
famille ça n'a plus rien à voir non mais
là où je vous rejoins c'est
effectivement quand vous êtes dans une
tradition qui est la tradition hara kiri
c'est-à-dire bête et méchant était
méchante c'était la tradition hara kiri
donc moi je suis pas du tout pour votre
boycott et c'est simplement à titre
personnel je n'irai pas voir vos
spectacles parce que je trouve cinq ans
pèsera longtemps jeu et en même temps je
vous le dis c'est pas faux bond à la
limite ce qui me gêne c'est votre
réaction c'est à dire la façon de que
vous avez de vous deux vous dédouaner en
disant c'est vous qui comprenait pas
bien voilà j'ai été maladroit moi je
veux bien convenir à un moment donné de
façon alors il ya eu il ya deux choses
cette blague je pense que s que encore
une fois c'était un candidat est ce que
c'était réellement intelligent de la
figer sur le net non ça ne l'était pas
est ce qu'il ya une instrumentalisation
qui a été faite de cette blague à des
fins ensuite de virer un propos
humoristiques pour le transformer en
politique ça c'est autre chose nicolas
pernikoff moi bon votre comportement on
dérange parce qu'à un moment donné ce
que j'aimerais entendre c est ce que
c'est une mauvaise blague je suis un
gros con je suis nul et voilà sur sa
direct et apprend la voix là et vous
excuser même pas ti pas ti c'est quand
même très limité bien sûr et emploie 2
dit alors je m'excuse j'ai été con et à
ce moment là il ya beaucoup de gens qui
vont vous l'entendre je ne suis pas juge
mais j'ai été extrêmement choqué quand
même beau se faire ce genre de là à
aller plus loin excusez une vague
l'ignoble oui on est sur ce registre est
ce que c'est une blague irresponsable et
un fauteuil j'ai un côté un peu
irresponsable quand j'ai peut-être pas
compris et je le paye aujourd'hui mais
alors vous excusez pas parce que le
problème ça vous dit oui la blague n'est
pas très bonne et puis c'est compliqué
parce que je vais pas pouvoir monter sur
scène machin mais ça moi je m'en fous
que vous montiez ou non sur scène que ou
que la salle ils vont pas fait tourner
avec lui l'accord a dit moi ce que
j'aimerais savoir c'est est-ce que vous
excusé pour ses propos qui sont ignobles
et encore plus aujourd'hui ou est-ce que
vous ne vous excusez pas parce que le
dcg le problème de petter vous ne vous
excusez pas juste quand on va voir quand
on va voir à quai à quelqu'un en
spectacle n'a pas sa place le cir il l'a
dit tout à l'heure vous payez votre
place vous faites chier vous partez tout
le monde le sait il ya du bad buzz et à
l'arrière ça va être vidé sauf que là le
problème c'est que vous utilisez un
médian c'est comme si vous exprimer à
télévisions annoncent donc les gens ils
subissent votre chevet ça avance que je
n'ai pas la même chose je suis pas le
premier rue maurice tas ne pas obtenir
un 100 % de réussite sur une blague je
pense que cameron avant moi bien sûr y
arriver mais ça ne vous excusez pas en
quoi dieu que c'est parce que qu'est-ce
que je dois m'excuser auprès de gens qui
me sont très chauds du moment les
gendarmes ont également changé mais aux
familles les jours où il était chaud et
d eau fraîche ou non
même totalement différent aujourd'hui
est ce qu'il ya des gens qui ont été
offensés est-ce que c'était intelligent
de la figer sur la mais vous dites que
vous parlez en votre âme et il n'y a pas
lieu de faire polémique nous dit chaque
fois là encore des lits d'ehpad machine
à voyager dans le temps donc il n'ya pas
lieu de faire polémique c'est pas à vous
de lire s'il ya lieu ou non mais oui
aujourd'hui s'il ya lieu de faire
polémique ce n'est pas moi c'est pas à
twitter c'est à la justice on te voir si
cette blague a été c'est l'homme que
j'aimerais entendre m aujourd'hui ma si
vous voulez entendre est-ce que je suis
content de cette blague est ce que c est
ce que vient d'anéantir huit ans de
travail n'y avait pas de somme et de
rigueur dans leurs parents ça mais je
suis désolée qu'elle est un média étant
je vais je vais te dire excuse moi c'est
vrai que voilà en fait ce qui est en
train de dire et je pense que c'est
c'est la petite nuance et qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui disent est ce que
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
est-ce que tu t'excuses que tu penses
vraiment hâte à blesser des gens que tu
pensais que tu es de mauvaise note ou
bien tu t'excuses parce que ça fait un
bordel derrière qui fait que ça mais ta
carrière en danger c'est ça le le mais
moi j'aime pas blesser les gens donc
c'est pour ça que je suis désolé d'en
être arrivés à un point où il ya les
gens ont compris des choses que je ne
prêtais pas à cette blague aujourd'hui
est ce que on a un problème à l'idée de
pouvoir faire des blagues aussi
choquantes qu'elles soient sans devoir
affronter un torrent de menaces je sais
plus moi je me suis un peu préservé je
vous le cache pas je suis monté à 30
milles menaces de mort donc la non moi
je peux pas c'est mon métier amandine
jauger et moi j'ai envie de dire dans
une tradition française j'ai envie de me
battre pour questionner les limites de
la liberté d'expression pour questionner
l'ambiance du pays et j'ai envie de
pouvoir faire des choses tout simplement